[Música]
sin acuerdos terminó la reunión entre
los convocantes de las manifestaciones
en colombia y el gobierno después de 13
días de protestas el comité nacional del
paro denunció falta de empatía y convocó
a una nueva gran jornada de protesta
mañana les explicamos sus peticiones
tiroteo en una escuela de kazán rus ya
deja al menos ocho muertos o siete
estudiantes y una profesora además de 21
heridos el tirador un joven de 19 años
ex alumno de la escuela y usuario
registrado con tenencia de armas fue
arrestado por la policía por ahora no
hay evidencia de más atacantes
y la liga árabe condenó los ataques
aéreos israelíes contra la franja de
gaza que han dejado al menos 24 muertos
incluidos 9 menores tras un fin de
semana de protestas y violencia que dejó
cientos de heridos en la recta final del
ramadán y tras aplazarse un mes en la
decisión de desalojo de palestinos de
jerusalén este
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
las noticias más importantes del mundo
en france 24 en colombia no hubo acuerdo
tras la primera reunión exploratoria
entre el comité nacional del paro y el
gobierno sin embargo el ejecutivo
anunció que está preparado para
concertar y poner fin a las protestas
que iniciaron el 28 de abril contra las
políticas del presidente iván duque al
final de este lunes el alto comisionado
para la paz y vocero para los diálogos
miguel ceballos anunció que hay plena
disposición para avanzar en la agenda
con acompañamiento de la iglesia
católica y de naciones unidas por su
parte el comité de convocantes del paro
llamo a nuevas protestas este miércoles
en 13 días de movilizaciones hay 47
muertos según varias ong del país cifra
diferente a la que tiene el gobierno de
27 fallecidos las protestas han llevado
a decenas de bloqueos de las vías y ya
hay desabastecimiento en algunas
ciudades veamos en qué consisten los
pedidos del comité del paro el gobierno
[Música]
el comité nacional de paro propone que
las campañas políticas sean financiadas
por el estado para evitar intercambios
de favores además piden reformas a los
organismos de control para evitar que
respondan a los intereses del gobierno
de turno y asimismo proponen establecer
que el voto sea obligatorio para que los
políticos no puedan ofrecer pagos a los
ciudadanos para ponerle fin a la
desigualdad proponen que se cree un
subsidio de desempleo que se establezca
el derecho constitucional a la vivienda
así como la gratuidad de un mínimo vital
de agua los campesinos no deberían pagar
peajes en las vías y los estratos más
bajos deberían tener internet gratis
además deberá haber educación gratuita y
de calidad y garantizar el acceso a la
salud para todos los ciudadanos en la
que el cuidado sanitario sea un derecho
y no un negocio como denuncian médicos
en la actualidad en cuanto a seguridad
se exige la eliminación del esmad así
como la creación de espacio de denuncia
de violaciones a los derechos humanos y
agregan que es necesario garantizar la
seguridad de los líderes sociales en
cuanto a sostenibilidad solicitan se
sometan a voto los proyectos de minero
extractiva de fracking para que las
propuestas sean financieramente
sostenibles el comité nacional de paro
propone que se establezcan programas de
regreso del dinero al estado como exigir
a los ricos que devuelvan al país el
dinero evadido en impuestos y paguen
mayores tributos así como el recorte de
embajadas y consulados y la exigencia a
los extranjeros en colombia a reinvertir
el dinero que ganan en el país
tras el primer acercamiento entre el
gobierno y el comité nacional del paro
de momento continuarán las protestas
previstas para este miércoles la
conversación de hoy es con uno de los
actores de las demandas ciudadanas nos
acompaña en france 24 alberto palmas
director de fundación familia camionera
y uno de los representantes de este
gremio quien nos puede dar un panorama
del futuro del paro alberto bienvenido a
france 24 y qué es lo que ustedes están
pidiendo después del anuncio de anoche
hecho por el vocero de los diálogos
miguel ceballos cambia la perspectiva de
las protestas
bueno un saludo a todos ustedes y desde
colombia les tratamos el siguiente
informe el ministerio de transporte en
vista de que el paro de camioneros se
fortaleció estableció unas mesas de
negociación y ayer a entre las 5 de la
tarde y las 10 de la noche se hizo una
reunión a la cual se están llegando a
los siguientes acuerdos por ejemplo se
pidió que se le reconociera al camionero
tradicional el precio mínimo de lo que
costaría un flete en condiciones
normales esto en razón a que los
intermediarios de carga se quedan hasta
con el 50 por ciento del flete que que
paga un generador de la carga
el ministerio ya expidió el primer
documento donde hace obligatorio que el
sistema de costos eficientes se respete
y que no se puede apagar por debajo de
lo que arroja esta tabla ese es el
primer punto el segundo punto es que
tenemos una
y una resolución que es perversa en el
sentido en que beneficia al camión viejo
y castiga al camión nuevo poniendo en un
orden de retraso la modernización de la
flota esto es que el camión viejo tiene
más preferencia y más beneficio que lo
que tendría un camión nuevo el
ministerio de transporte se compromete a
hacer una resolución para que todos los
camiones tengan los mismos beneficios y
preferencia ando en todo momento en la
seguridad de las vías también tiene unos
puntos adicionales como que en el
sistema de pensiones y parafiscales en
colombia' que el distrito está haciendo
unos cobros excesivos al camionero
tradicional por la cantidad de dinero
que ellos nueve en razón de su trabajo
quiero preguntarle sobre el tema alberto
precisamente disculpe que lo interrumpa
pero es que tenemos poco tiempo y
quisiera abarcar la mayor cantidad de
temas porque la de usted
es una de las protestas que genera mayor
presión al gobierno en el día 14 de paro
con todas estas exigencias que ustedes
están haciendo hay unos 120 bloqueos de
vidas que ya se empiezan a notar con
desabastecimiento en algunas ciudades y
le quiero preguntar ustedes creen que
esta es la única manera para que el
gobierno los escuche hasta cuando irán
los bloqueos teniendo en cuenta el
panorama de escasez de alimentos y de
medicamentos y además en medio de la
pandemia
bueno lo que quiero decirle es que no se
debe estigmatizar ni culpar a una acción
de defensa que están haciendo los
camineros tradicionales por convierte el
camionero toma una vía de hecho porque
el el gobierno desde su posesión se ha
negado a prestarle las soluciones que
está exigiendo el camionero la única
solución que tiene el camionero es no
cargar y no cargar es que el país se
desabastece nosotros como representantes
del sector tradicional de carga estamos
absolutamente seguros que si el
camionero tradicional para la economía
se paraliza como efectivamente está
ocurriendo el gobierno si conoce de esta
situación pero nunca le dio solución a
las peticiones de nosotros la misma
ministra de transporte dice que ha hecho
280 mesas de trabajo con nosotros eso es
cierto pero es 280 mesas de trabajo
nunca tomo decisiones
de ahí que llegamos a este escenario que
estamos viendo y por eso le quiero
preguntar pues otro tema es que
elementos están ustedes dejando pasar
por los corredores humanitarios porque
los productores pues evidentemente como
usted lo describe ya están desesperados
porque tienen su producto varado en las
fincas y con posibilidad de perderse o
ejemplos como el de la industria avícola
que no tiene concentrado para alimentar
a los animales y le pido muy rápidamente
que ya se nos va acabando el tiempo
los campesinos cargo ya en el paro
camionero porque los campesinos dicen
que muchas veces y han perdido a las
consciencias por culpa del gobierno que
si en este momento tienen una perdida
pero que van a tener un un respaldo y un
beneficio apoyar selva roca en dinero lo
están haciendo
o sea que el campesino está apoyando el
paro nacional y en el caso de la
industria de la industria avícola de
estas cuestiones se están haciendo lo
que nosotros denominamos corredores de
vida que es que únicamente pasan por
estos sitios alimentos alimentos para
los animales avituallamiento para
las ciudades medicinas gases oxígeno
etcétera lo que no está pasando son los
otros productos que realmente no son
digamos como tan necesarios en este
momento pero los de primera necesidad
los esenciales si están pasando lo
estamos dejando pasar en los 120 puntos
a nivel nacional
le agradezco muchísimo por su valioso
tiempo gracias por entregarnos un
panorama y su visión sobre lo que está
sucediendo en las carreteras de colombia
que tenga un feliz día
vamos a continuar con más noticias en
france 24 en rusia 7 niños y niñas
fallecieron en un tiroteo en una escuela
de la ciudad de kazán además de una
profesora y hay al menos 21 heridos por
el ataque de un joven de 19 años usuario
registrado como tenedor de armas y quien
fue arrestado por la policía el jefe de
las regiones de tatarstán él calificó el
ataque como una gran tragedia para todo
el país y dijo que no había evidencia de
que nadie más hubiera estado involucrado
más detalles con nuestro corresponsal en
moscú xavier colás
todo comenzó con un asaltante que empezó
a caminar con un arma automática por la
entrada principal de la escuela
inmediatamente abrió fuego contra la
gente que tenía delante la policía rusa
acordonó la zona y ya a esa hora
empezaban a compartirse en redes
sociales rusas vídeos de niños saltando
por la ventana y otras escenas de pánico
un atacante ha sido detenido se trata de
un joven de 19 años que estudió en el
pasado en esa misma escuela las armas
estaban registradas a su nombre los
niños evacuados de la escuela de caza no
han tenido lugar este tiroteo han sido
reubicados en escuelas infantiles
cercanas y se les está brindando
asistencia psicológica a ellos y también
a los familiares antes del asalto a la
escuela el atacante se abrió un canal en
la red social de telegram y dejó allí
varios mensajes se fotografió delante de
un espejo con una inscripción en la que
pone dios y anunció que iba a causar una
matanza y que después se iba a pegar un
tiro
desde la franja de gaza sigue el
lanzamiento de hasta 200 cohetes hacia
israel que responde con más bombardeos
al menos 24 palestinos fallecieron
incluidos 9 niños
el movimiento yihad islámica anunció que
dos de sus líderes también murieron
mientras tanto la onu y la liga árabe
rechazaron los ataques al final del
ramadán y por la previsible decisión de
desalojar a palestinos de jerusalén este
y los paramédicos se evacuaron a varios
fieles musulmanes heridos durante los
enfrentamientos en la mezquita de
al-aqsa también conocida como el monte
del templo
también estábamos sentados en al aqsa
cuando entró un gran número de policías
arrojaron botes de gas lacrimógeno en
granadas paralizantes
dispararon balas de goma e intentaron
sacarnos de al aqsa pero muchos jóvenes
lograron permanecer adentro
al mediodía del lunes unas 200 personas
habían sido trasladadas a hospitales
tratamos lesiones en la cabeza estable
acciones en los ojos muchas de ellas
heridas en el estómago man ya varios
médicos también resultaron heridos
abdomen
horas más tarde a los fieles musulmanes
se les permitió regresar a la mezquita
pero la policía mantuvo alejados a
algunos de los palestinos más jóvenes
para evitar nuevos enfrentamientos vete
a casa ahora te dije que es hora de ir a
casa cuidado
la ira aumenta en otra parte del este de
jerusalén
los nacionalistas judíos presionan para
desalojar a varios palestinos de sus
hogares luego de que un tribunal
dictaminará que sus casas fueron
construidas en terrenos propiedad de
judíos
esto significa que mi país mi gobierno
está conmigo ahora no con los
terroristas
[Aplausos]
los nacionalistas judíos habían planeado
marchar a través de jerusalén para
celebrar la unificación de la ciudad y
de paso la anexión de los vecindarios
palestinos
la marcha que significa una provocación
para muchos fue prohibida en los barrios
musulmanes por primera vez en siete años
palestinos de gaza dispararon cohetes
hacia jerusalén
y la población de china registró el
crecimiento demográfico más lento en
décadas creció un 5 38 por ciento hasta
los 2.400 11 millones de habitantes en
los últimos 10 años según el censo de
2020 el primero desde el 2010 en cuanto
al crecimiento anual de este censo
refleja una media del 0.53 por ciento de
aumento en la última década frente al
0,57 por ciento del período 2000 a 2010
y el 107 por ciento entre 1990 y 2000
nada comparado con la época de finales
de los 70 y principios de los 80 cuando
la población de china crecía a una media
anual del 2,1 por ciento lo que hace
pensar que en los próximos años su
imparable crecimiento desde hace 50 años
se revertirá
inicio del segundo proceso en la demanda
de la unión europea contra el
laboratorio astrazéneca por los retrasos
en la entrega de dosis en la apertura
del caso la defensa del bloque pide al
laboratorio sueco británico que entregue
al menos 120 millones de inyecciones de
su vacuna contra kobe 19 para finales de
junio
originalmente astrazéneca tenía que
entregar 300 millones de dosis en ese
plazo pero hasta ahora sólo ha dado 50
millones
y en una ceremonia que es tradición en
el reino unido la reina isabel segunda
presento al parlamento británico la
lista de leyes que el actual gobierno
quiere gestionar este año con el plan de
vacunación en una etapa avanzada y tras
disminuir los niveles de contagios boris
johnson no planea avanzar con su agenda
de nivelación es un discurso de la reina
isabel dijo que la prioridad del
gobierno es lograr la recuperación de la
pandemia que haga el reino unido más
fuerte más sano y más próspero que antes
hasta aquí el informativo siga con
nosotros en france 24 buenos días
[Música]